Today's 1 Minute Monday is "Do one thing".
If you're starting up in any new project, you're going to be quickly overwhelmed by the
number of options.
There's so many things you have to do, so many ways to go
that you don't end up doing anything.
Pick one thing, focus on that and get it done.
And you'll realize over the weeks that you are actually getting stuff done.
This came as a result of a coaching call I had with my media coach,
who gives me advice on how to make my YouTube videos better, radio shows better
and last week she gave me... 30 different options of things that I need to work on.
And they were all great, I need to work on them.
But because they were so overwhelming, in the past week I did nothing,
I didn't touch any of them, because it was too much.
So I told her today on the call: "give me one thing, give me one assignment,
I trust your judgement, give me one thing I need to work on and I´ll do it,
I'll get it done!" And she said: "Ok, do a 1 Minute Monday, that's your project this week."
So this is my 1 Minute Monday.
If you have anything big and it's scary and overwhelming and preventing you from moving
forward on taking action, pick one thing to do this week, follow through on it,
and do one more next week, and one more next week until you get them all done.
Believe!
If you guys like this new format, let me know, give it a thumbs up,
leave a comment. I'll see you soon!
Subtitles by the Amara.org community